chers collègues beaux jours j'espère que
tout le monde me voit et l'entend
aujourd'hui nous sommes en ligne avec
tous les dirigeants de régions de russie
nous allons parler des résultats de
notre travail de la situation concrète
dans chaque entité de la fédération et
ce sont des problématiques nous allons
résoudre ensemble je vous rappelle que
le 2 avril j'ai signé un décret selon
lesquels pour la période jusqu'au 30
avril compris était une période chômée
et les dirigeants des régions ont reçu
des instructions complémentaire de
mesures de prévention ceci a permis
d'assurer une approche souple et
évidemment d'appliquer des mesures de
limitation pour l'ensemble de la
population non pas de façon unilatérale
mais adapté en fonction des citoyens des
situations et appliqué aux nécessités
locales qu'est ce que nous avons reçus
verts nous sommes mobilisés nous avons
mobilisé toutes nos ressources et je
citerai simplement quelques chiffres qui
sont mises à jour qui augmente chaque
jour
par exemple les respirateurs les
respirateurs artificiels et est produit
au nombre de d'une soixantaine par mois
maintenant 800 par mois mois d'avril
elles seront à presque mille ha au mois
de mai nous devrions en avoir beaucoup
plus
d'ici la fin de l'année la russie a
lancé la production à partir de zéro
d'un certain nombre de produits qui
n'existaient pas chez nous ça peut être
des systèmes de test la production a été
multiplié par neuf en mars et avril
et si on avait par exemple 2000
analyse par jour qui était fait on est
aujourd'hui à 150 milles par jour
donc on voit une multiplication par 60
et cette capacité de mener des tests va
être augmenté à la fin d'avril du nous
sommes à cent mille costumes de
protection individuelle pour les
médecins et nous devrions à arriver à
150 milles au mois de mai tout ceci
c'est beaucoup mais par rapport à ce que
nous pouvons faire c'est encore peu ce
n'est pas suffisant les costumes de
protection complète pour le père dit
qu'un personnel médical qui travaillent
directement dans une zone de risques
qu'on appelle la zone rouge sont
actuellement produits en grandes
vitesses est livrée à grande vitesse
nous menons également des importations
d'urgence nous augmentons la production
d'un même temps il y a toujours un
déficit en sur certaines références et
je demande au gouvernement d'organiser
ce de prendre les mesures nécessaires
pour augmenter la production tous les
jours et je prie le ministère de suivre
l'exécution de ces mesures
d'augmenter les capacités des de la part
des régions aux pme il faut ici aussi
augmenter les réserves le fonds de
réserve du ministère de la santé
publique et il fallait il fallait
augment augmenter jusqu'à dix neuf mille
places supplémentaires en lit d'hôpital
pour le 29 avril donc tous les jours je
reçois des informations mais un jour et
je sais que en gros les nécessités sont
satisfaites on est à aujourd'hui à 16
milles c'est bien mais c'est un tableau
général pour le pays ce que je veux
c'est que dans chaque région on est une
une capacité à 100% de résident de
résister à la menace qui ne fait de quoi
ce qui me paraît important de souligner
aussi face à cette épidémie de qourna
virus tout pays toute la planète tous
les pays ont été confrontés pour la
première fois nous connaissons
maintenant cette maladie nous la
connaissons beaucoup mieux qu'il ya
encore très peu de temps donc nous
sommes capables de mettre en place d une
stratégie des prévisions et une tactique
concrètes sur les actes un bon à prendre
et quand l'expérience étrangère que
l'expérience en russie montrent que les
décisions qui ont été prises hier dès
demain et dès après-demain peuvent
s'avérer insuffisante donc je demande au
ministère de la santé de suivre un
d'assurer un suivi tous les jours et au
niveau de chaque entité de la fédération
que les informations soient mises à jour
constamment puisqu'on sait que cette
situation évolue chaque jour je le
répète encore une fois il faut agir en
anticipant et s'il le faut nous
prendrons des mesures complémentaires
pour la mise en place de lits d'hôpitaux
supplémentaires et nos réserves qui sont
prêtes aujourd'hui peuvent ne pas ne pas
m'être ne pas être suffisant donc il
faut être prêt à tout scénario
d'évolution et je suis là que je
m'adresse aux dirigeants des régions
si vous avez un blanc de mise en place
de lits d'hôpitaux supplémentaires ce
n'est certainement pas une raison
d'arrêter votre travail ou des
considérez vous avez rempli votre
mission au contraire utiliser chaque
possibilité pour augmenter ses
ressources et votre capacité à réagir au
niveau des agents sans attendre des
ordres venant des échelons supérieurs
autre point important c'est bien sûr la
présence de lits d'hôpitaux spécialisés
c'est important mais il faut que
l'ensemble du corps médical plus
travailler parce que s'il ya des
problèmes s'il manque de spécialistes il
ya un surcharge
si il ya une mauvaise gestion des flux
il faut une aide en temps voulu au bon
moment puisque il ya des gens qui
connaissent des complications je le
répète encore une fois il faut que
chaque maillon de ce mécanisme unifié
puisse réagir en souplesse et rapidement
qu'il s'agisse du diagnostic des
services d'ambulance d'urgence et je
sais qu'aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs c'est le 28 avril qu'on fait
aujourd'hui normalement les services
d'urgences d'ailleurs j'en profite pour
souhaiter une bonne fête à tous ce
personnel qui travaille aujourd'hui
intensément je salue le travail que vous
faites dans cette situation de surcharge
vous faites preuve de courage vous
faites preuve des meilleures qualités
humaines et
je pense que précisément ce serait gay
opportun de fêter aujourd'hui la journée
de du personnel médical d'urgence
nous nous orientons une grande quantité
de spécialistes aujourd'hui sur la lutte
contre le corps nageuses mais il ya
d'autres disciplines qui sont
importantes qu'il s'agisse d'oncologie
de cardiologie de 7h à et on ne peut pas
abandonner ceux qui sont malades
aujourd'hui de ces maladies et de dire
attendez aujourd'hui nous sommes
situation difficile c'est ça veut dire
que tout le monde doit aujourd'hui
recevoir une aide appropriée
par ailleurs pour soutenir l'économie
russe
encore une fois il est important de
soutenir de maintenir l'emploi et les
salaires nous avons alloué des
ressources absolument sans précédent
les décisions ont été prises en quelques
heures
nous avons étudié l'aspect législatif de
ces mesures nous avons lance prix
adopter ces mesures il faut maintenant
assurer leur exécution et jeu j'attire
votre attention sur le fait que les
responsabilités sont personnelles pour
tous les dirigeants et on considérera
que la mission était remplie si toutes
les familles nombreuses les familles de
petits enfants le personnel médical aura
reçu l'aide matérielle financière qui
leur était destiné on voit que ces
problèmes sont fréquents donc ici un
problème de contrôle qui doit être
maintenu et qui ne sera pas le vrai et
enfin point important que je tiens à
dire c'est que en faisant le bilan des
semaines passées
je vois que nous avons réussi à freiner
la propagation de cet événement
c'est le résultat du travail que nous
avons mené ensemble la responsabilité de
millions de citoyens qui ont suivi les
recommandations des médecins et des
spécialistes qui ont pris soin de leur
santé de la santé de leurs proches qui
ont rempli les instructions données par
les autorités
évidemment chaque heure nous avons de
nouvelles de nouveaux cas de maladie
ceci s'est un peu ralentie mais cela ne
doit pas nous donner un précèdent pour
se reposer
je suis en contact permanent avec nos
spécialistes avec le décideur et tous
sont d'accord sur le fait que le pic de
l'épidémie n'a pas encore été franchie
nous sommes dans la période la plus
tendue de cette lutte contre l'épidémie
et nous arrivons ici un niveau de menace
très élevé cette menace demeure elle
menace elle peut toucher chacun d'entre
nous et tout ce que nous devons faire
encore ici c'est important et là je vais
que chacun d'entre nous aura besoin de
discipline de mobilisation de capacités
à travailler pour que enfin cette vague
d'épidémie puisse enfin redescendre et
nous devons être prêts à retirer les
limitations les restrictions pas à pas
au cas par cas
évidemment nous avons tous nous
attendons tous le moment de nous
retrouver de travailler normalement et
aujourd'hui il faut que tous les
citoyens de russie respecte toutes les
règles de confinement et de quarantaine
correctement et plus nous le ferons plus
ne sont aptes à sortir de ce confinement
mais encore une fois s'appuyer sur
l'idée que la menace est passée ce
serait
imprudents et se serait même dangereux
par conséquent j'ai pris la décision
suivante première chose nous allons
bientôt avoir les fêtes de mai et donc
les journées de travail 6 7 8 mai nous
savons que d'habitude
souvent les gens prennent des journées
de congé ou chaumet et aujourd'hui étant
donné le risque qui demeure jeu se
propose de déclarer ces trois jours
chômés avec maintien salaires c'est à
dire que l'ensemble des fêtes de mai
sera jusqu'au 11 mai compris cearà
période chômée avec le strict respect
des mesures de prévention qui ont été
adoptées pour les agents deuxième point
les dirigeants des régions conservent
toutes les compétences supplémentaires
qui leur ont été accordés et j'attire
votre attention chers collègues il faut
travailler de façon adaptée en fonction
de la menace sur votre tête
il est complètement exclu de prendre des
décisions basées sur les émotions ou
simplement par souhait de copier les
autres vous ne pouvez que faire plus de
mal et par conséquent troisième point
étant donné que les temps donna dispersé
disparités de la situation dans les
régions dans certaines la menace est
apparu plus tard dans d'autres
la menace a presque disparu donc les
mesures de confinement de précaution
sont différentes
de même que
quand il ya le pic épidémique qui sera
dépassée dans l'ensemble du pays on sait
que dans certaines régions il ne sera
pas encore passé donc on ne peut pas
adopter les mêmes mesures partout et les
mêmes mesures de restriction donc nous
devons être prête au fait que nous
allons encore passer des moments
difficiles à haut risque donc il faut
faire preuve de responsabilité de
résistance pour ne pas gâcher tout ce
que nous avons fait et qui nous a coûté
tant défaut tant d'efforts et je
j'enjoins l' agence de sécurité de la
consommation d'ici une semaine pour le 5
mai d'émettre des recommandations des
critères sur les étapes détaillées deux
sorties du confinement
il était évident que en fonction de la
situation épidémiologique et des
prévisions qui ont été faites
nous nous adapterons donc les
recommandations de vente est envoyé aux
régions le plus tôt possible pour que
les régions et en plus une semaine
supplémentaire d'ici le 11 mai pour
s'adapter pour adapter ses décisions en
fonction de leur situation locale donc
pas de décisions autonomes mais une
décision en concertation en fonction de
la situation locale et en consultation
avec les spécialistes
donc peut-être que dans certains
territoires il faudra renforcer ces
restrictions peut-être qu'au contraire
dans d'autres il faudra les adoucir
et que le régime de confinement sera
peut-être levé étape par étape et pas
d'un seul coup les secteurs du bâtiment
de l'agriculture le secteur tertiaire
tout cela vous devez être prêt à subir à
vivre une période difficile mais il ne
faut pas trop anticiper pour ne pas
risquer de retomber en arrière quatrième
quand l'épidémie a fortement frappé
notre économie
beaucoup d'entreprises d'auto
entrepreneur ont été frappés ou des
entreprises familiales où les gens ont
investi pendant des années leurs efforts
leur argent leurs ressources matérielles
tout cela
tous ces gens là où besoin d'un soutien
et je donne ordre au gouvernement de
mettre en place un nouveau paquet de
mesures de soutien aux citoyens ce n'est
pas tout je demande également au
gouvernement de s'entendre avec les
régions et les grandes entreprises pour
mettre en place un plan d'action
national de normalisation de la vie de
restauration de l'emploi des salaires et
aussi tout simplement de reprise
économique
c'est maintenant que nous devons mettre
en place l injure les élaboré pour que
nous puissions mettre en place un
programme 100% validé synchronisée en
fonction de la situation épidémiologique
et jeu du confinement tels qu'ils se
déroulent
c'est une
c'est un programme stratégique national
qui doit permettre de procéder un
changement structurel de l'économie qui
doit correspondre à l'évolution de cette
la situation dans le monde aujourd'hui